everyone knows green goblin from the
spider-man movies but it's a special few
who know about his time in spider-punk's
spider army during the edge of
spider-geddon curious what we're talking
about keep watching
nowadays it might seem like common
knowledge that norman osborne is the
green goblin but the goblins identity
was once actually a mystery to readers
from the character's first appearance in
amazing spider-man number 14 it would be
two years 25 issues and one major artist
change before the green goblin was
unmasked that artist change even helped
feed an urban legend about the goblin
one that has survived for years amazing
spider-man number 38 was spidey
co-creator steve ditko's final issue as
the comics artist john ramita senior
replaced ditko with amazing spider-man
number 39 which happens to be the issue
in which goblin's identity is revealed
goblin being unmasked as soon as ditko
left the title led many fans to believe
that ditko was against osborne being
green goblin and that this was why he
left spider-man's other co-creator has
seemed to confirm half of this fan
theory in a 2011 issue of the magazine
alter ego stan lee said ditko wanted
goblin to be just some character that we
had never seen before but lee insisted
that would be cheating readers however
by the time ditko left amazing
spider-man he and lee were embroiled in
so many financial conflicts that ditco's
departure from the title was inevitable
regardless of any creative differences
that said in a 2009 essay ditko not only
denied lee's claims that he was against
osborne being the goblin but says he
always knew osborne would be the goblin
and that he made plenty of creative
choices to facilitate that future reveal
norman osborne is hardly the only
character to bear the name green goblin
in fact while he's the original most
memorable and most enduring version of
the character he's only one of five
different characters to have used the
name just as norman's son harry becomes
new goblin in 2007's spider-man 3 harry
also assumes the name of green goblin in
1974's amazing spider-man number 136
after discovering peter parker was
spider-man
look at little goblin junior
gonna cry
the third goblin is dr bart hamilton a
psychiatrist who treats harry osborn
hamilton uses hypnosis to learn green
goblin's secrets including the location
of his hideout and equipment visiting
the hideout hamilton gives in to
temptation and becomes the next goblin
beginning in 1978's amazing spider-man
number 176 green goblin number four
tries his hand at the hero business phil
urich son of daily bugle reporter ben
urich recovers the goblin equipment
after harry osborne's death and even
enjoys a short-lived solo title eurek
retires after his equipment is damaged
beyond repair during the 1996 onslaught
event after returning from the dead for
a few decades norman osborne orders the
creation of a genetically engineered
minion designed to be the new green
goblin in 2000's peter parker spider-man
number 18. he dresses as the goblin and
acts like the goblin all to help osborne
convince the world he was never the
green goblin in the first place
eventually green goblin became more than
just spider-man's enemy how well as it
happened he was helped out by a bunch of
green skinned guys with pointy ears
during the 2006 civil war event norman
osborne is appointed director of a new
version of the thunderbolts a group
tasked with capturing unregistered
superheroes osborne's thunderbolts
include villains who are a little
nastier than the team is used to
including the kill crazy villain
bullseye and the deadly symbiote venom
osborne's leadership role in the
thunderbolts puts him in a position to
be in the right place at the right time
when secret invasion comes along focused
on the shape-shifting scrolls secret
invasion has most of marvel's heroes
uniting against this new alien threat
osborne later succeeds in gaining the
public's trust by shooting and killing
the skrull queen varanki when the dust
settles tony stark is blamed for the
scroll infiltration and ousted as
director of shield while osborne is made
the head of the new military force
hammer from there his power keeps on
growing
when green goblin gains control of
hammer the superhero registration act is
still in effect and most of the
surviving former avengers are considered
outlaws osborne takes advantage of this
situation and forms his own team of dark
avengers most of osborne's dark avengers
are villains renamed and rebranded as
the replacements for more traditional
avengers bullseye is disguised as
hawkeye dawkin as wolverine venom as
spider-man and moonstone as ms marvel
novar aka marvel boy joins the team as a
new captain marvel the only holdouts
from pre-osborn avengers teams are the
mentally unstable sentry and the morally
questionable war god aries osborne's
influence is finally put to bed at the
conclusion of the 2010 line-wide event
siege in which osborne leads a failed
invasion of asgard and is finally
arrested and imprisoned for his crimes
it tested well with focus groups all
right i am iron patriots
if you've seen iron man 3 then you'll
already know the name iron patriot what
you may not know is that in the comics
iron patriot originally had nothing to
do with colonel james rhodes
combining the design of stark's iron man
armor with the colors of captain america
norman osborne creates the iron patriot
armor so he can use it to lead his dark
avengers the armor gives him most of
iron man's abilities though unlike
stark's armor it isn't based on repulsor
technology norman also creates the
american sun armor for his son harry but
the younger osborne would eventually
discover that norman did it just so he
could eventually kill harry in order to
create public sympathy for himself
norman remains iron patriot until his
plans fall apart in siege he eventually
escapes from the raft and forms a new
team of dark avengers in the hopes of
recapturing his old suit and getting his
revenge on the heroes who defeated him
he fails of course and soon after
resumes his life as the green goblin
norman osborne's most sickeningly
powerful transformation comes at the end
of 2018's amazing spider-man number 798
osborne is one of the first people to
figure out peter parker is spider-man
but the events of the 2007 storyline one
more day takes that knowledge away from
him in amazing spider-man number 797
when j jonah jameson mentions green
goblin's killing of gwen stacy the words
spark something in osborne and cause him
to remember who spider-man is with this
new revelation goblin demands spidey
quit being a hero or he'll kill all the
important people in parker's life
osborne also attacks the offices of the
daily bugle and after an intense battle
with spider-man winds up impaled on
debris spidey thinks goblin's dying but
the issue ends with the carnage symbiote
appearing and bonding with osborne to
create the red goblin as the red goblin
osbourne is more powerful than ever and
doesn't even suffer the usual symbiote
vulnerabilities to fire and sound red
goblin continues the hunt for parker's
loved ones and spidey is only able to
prevent the killing of ant-may and mj
with the help of venom anti-venom and
the superior octopus borrowing venom's
symbiote and allied with his old friend
flash thompson spidey is finally able to
defeat the red goblin although flash is
killed during the battle
the 2014 marvel comics event
spider-verse introduced dozens of
alternate reality versions of spider-man
then in 2018 spider-geddon brought in
even more alternate spideys including a
norman osborne version of the character
edge of spider-geddon number four
introduces the spider-man of earth 44145
in that reality norman osborne gained
spider abilities instead of peter parker
and even grew four extra arms in the
process this version of norman osborne
is forcefully recruited into the new
spider army by spider punk but by the
end of spider geddon it seems clear that
everyone would have been better off
leaving him at home allying himself only
with spider's man of earth 11580
the osborne spidey abandons the spider
army and chooses to destroy the web of
life and destiny that allows the
different spider heroes to travel
between other realities after
spider-geddon this character acts as the
final adversary for the reformed auto
octavius in the 2019 volume of superior
spider-man
most recently in the comics norman
osborne has turned to the side of the
angels though you could make the
argument it wasn't by his own choice
shortly after being made the director of
ravencroft institute by mayor wilson
fisk osborne finds himself in the
crosshairs of a resurrected vigilante
the supernatural villain kindred had
brought the sin eater back to life and
this time he has powers worthy of his
namesake rather than just killing his
prey the new sin eater can wipe away his
target's sins which is precisely what he
does to norman in 2020's amazing
spider-man number 50. while he believes
senator is going to kill him norman
instead wakes to find his evil urges
have disappeared replaced only with
remorse for everything he's done
understandably it takes spider-man a
while to accept that osborne's changes
are genuine and the wall crawler beats
the heck out of him in 2021's amazing
spider-man number 57 spidey fortunately
stops himself before he goes too far for
the time being osborne seems to be on
the right side of things in fact he does
what little he can to help spider-man
during the 2021 sinister war event but
considering who he is it's probably only
a matter of time before the green goblin
flies again
nearly two decades after 2002's
spider-man helped usher in the dominance
of superheroes on the big screen willem
dafoe had some pretty wonderful things
to say about his experience playing the
green goblin speaking to gq in february
2019 defoe talked about how the osborne
green goblin duality appealed to him
you could play these scenes where
it would switch from comedy to drama
in a line
as an example defoe singled out the
scene in which osborne and green goblin
have a conversation with one another in
a mirror he told gq that director sam
raimi even gave him robert lewis
stevenson's novel the strange case of dr
jekyll and mr hyde to read for the scene
during his sit-down with gq defoe
repeatedly mentions how much fun he had
during his experience on spider-man and
it must have been worth it too
considering the role's considerable
physical challenges in a
behind-the-scenes feature on the
spider-man dvd defoe claimed to have
endured between 40 and 50 hours of
fittings of the goblin suit before the
design was finalized defoe said it was
really uncomfortable to wear it was so
tight and so heavy that after a whole
day in that thing you felt like you had
just gone 12 rounds
early in june 2019 the anonymous leaker
known as roger wardell unleashed a
torrent of supposed leaks about mcu's
phase 4. while many of these leaks
remain unconfirmed it's only fair to
mention that this same person leaked
accurate details about avengers end game
months before the movie's release among
other things wardell had some major
claims about the green goblin according
to the alleged leaks phase 4's primary
antagonist won't be a purple guy from
outer space but someone much closer to
home yes wardell claims that norman
osborne will supposedly serve as the
next big bad of the mcu of course it's
now known that willem dafoe's version of
green goblin is on his way to the mcu
defoe will reprise the villainous role
in spider-man no way home but it remains
to be seen whether he'll replace thanos
as marvel's main villain considering
osborne and the other spider-man
villains appearing will be travelers
from other parts of the multiverse one
of the more likely outcomes of the story
would seem to be their return to their
respective realities not only that but
jonathan major's king the conqueror has
been frequently cited as the true big
bad of phase four but it's likely that
kevin feige and company won't be able to
resist introducing their own version of
norman osborn at some point or another
and who knows what might happen with him
only time will tell check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and tv shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]